es gibt am Jahresende jetzt auch ein
paar gute Nachrichten das war ein
wirklich schwieriges Jahr der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine der leider
noch andauert hat dafür gesorgt dass die
Energiepreise explodiert sind es war
eine hohe Unsicherheit bei Ihnen als
VerbraucherInnen aber auch bei vielen
Unternehmen und jetzt haben wir heute
glaube ich was wichtiges geschafft
nämlich dass wir bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitstellen als Bund mit den
Ländern gemeinsam um eben diese hohen
Preise abzufedern auf der Strom auf der
Gasseite die zweite gute Nachricht ist
wir werden auch Versorgungssicherheit
hinkriegen diesen Winter das war nicht
selbstverständlich wir haben volle
gasspeichert jetzt langsam übrigens
beginnen sich zu lehren aber da wir auch
Energie einsparen was sehr wichtig ist
werden wir das diesen Winter schaffen
und wir werden auch dauerhaft wieder
günstigere Preise kriegen also das Thema
Inflation packen wir an und wir werden
das auch in den Griff kriegen so das
klingt erstmal nach einem guten
versprechen 200 Milliarden wenn Schulden
gemacht das sind Schulden das sind
Schulden die aber notwendig sind weil
ansonsten einfach viele VerbraucherInnen
jetzt in dieser kurzfristigen Krise die
ja sehr heftig ist sozial mächtig unter
die Räder geraten werden und für manche
ist es immer noch schwierig das weiß ich
auch aber ich glaube wir haben jetzt
viel getan mit belastungspaketen
insbesondere auch für die unteren
Einkommen und für die Unternehmen ist es
wichtig dass sie wieder
Planungssicherheit haben und das haben
sie mit dem heutigen Tag
nichtsdestotrotz ist die Krise nicht
vorbei wir werden auch weiter Energie
einsparen das hilft uns auch die Preise
weiter zu senken wir werden es Angebot
ausweiten bei Gast bei der erneuerbaren
Energien das heißt wir haben glaube ich
eine ganz gute Strategie jetzt für die
nächste Zeit aber entscheidend ist
natürlich dass wir uns ja als auch raus
ich kaufen sondern raus finden indem wir
die Erneuerbaren Effizienz Einsparung
die neuen Technologien jetzt ganz
konsequent auf dem Markt bringen
sie sitzen schon auf heißen Kohlen dass
man das in den Zusammenhang überhaupt
noch sagen also geht die Politik hier
wieder mit zum Gießkannenprinzip vor ja
ganz Deutschland sitzt zurzeit auf
heißen Kohlen weil ohne Kohle wäre es
kalt zurzeit das ist mal ganz klar sagen
und die verteufelten fossilen
energiestoffe gegen die ein kleiner
Kreuzzug von Grünen und anderen
kalt momentan retten uns Gas und Kohle
muss man einfach sagen ist momentan so
ähm ich habe es nicht bis die letzte
verästigung die heutigen Gesetze
durchgelesen aber ich muss zur Kenntnis
nehmen das jemand der sich eigentlich
auskennen muss nämlich der bete
Präsident und deutscher Industrie gesagt
hat mit dieser Regelung lassen lässt man
uns die Unternehmen nämlich im Regen
stehen wirklich zitieren das ist von
heute die Politik liegt mit ihrer
Ignoranz gegenüber den betrieblichen
Realitäten die Axt an die grundpfeile
des Standorts Deutschland das sagt
siegfriedrichsform bitte die Präsident
der eingebunden war in die Vorbereitung
der Energiekommission und dem heute
wirklich der Kragen geplatzt ist der
gesagt das ist zu bürokratisch
Unternehmen wissen nicht wann kriegen
sie es sie wissen nicht genau wie sie es
beantragen es gibt eine kappungs Grenze
man muss vorher schon nachweisen dass
man 40 Prozent Umsatzeinbuße haben wird
wie soll das denn gehen also zu spät zu
wenig zu bürokratisch er ist völlig
verzweifelt und das zunächst mal eine
Stimme ich kann mir das nicht alles eins
zu eins zu eigen machen aber diese
Stimme muss man doch ernst nehmen und es
spricht für mich jetzt nicht für gutes
Regierungshandeln dass man nach langem
langen Verhandlungen mit einem Ergebnis
heute soll das Hohe Haus geht doch die
Mehrheit bekommt und dem der daran
beteiligt war wird der BDI präsent sagt
danach alles nur Murks also warum ging
man da nicht mehr auf ihn ein warum hat
man das nicht vorher schon
berücksichtigt ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass der Bild die Präsident
ist alles erfunden hat was ich da
zitiert habe können Sie gerne direkt
drauf eingehen ja ich war sogar gerade
beim BDI vor dieser Sendung also wird
eine Veranstaltung gemacht
und kann Ihnen sagen dass die Stimmung
nicht so ist wie er sie schildert
natürlich sind Unternehmen nicht
zufrieden wenn sie groß sind dann müssen
sie jetzt ein sehr viel Geld kriegen
dann auch auf Boni und Dividenden
verzichten auf der Vorstandsetage das
findet nicht jeder toll weil ein aber
ich finde das ist auch ein Preis jemand
zahlen kann gerade wenn man 50 100 oder
mehr Millionen Euro dann Zuschuss kriegt
nächstes Jahr ansonsten kann ich sagen
wir haben ein Problem was noch nicht
endgültig gelöst ist das ist diese
Obergrenze also es gibt halt ein paar
Konzerne chemische Industrie
insbesondere die würden auch gerne halbe
Milliarde Euro in Anspruch nehmen und
den Zuschüssen wenn sie nicht eh schon
wieder auf dem Markt einkaufen können
können nämlich manche schon Strompreise
sind gesunken und das ist ein Problem
was wir noch mit der europäischen Ebene
endgültig klären müssen aber sie sehen
kein Stromproblem keine ganz Problem
kein Ölproblem ab Januar es hängt
wirklich davon ab dass wir jetzt weiter
Energie einsparen und man muss auch
sagen jetzt haben wir sehr kalte Tage
gerade da verlieren wir an einem Tag bis
zu 1% vom gastspeicher das muss man ganz
anders sagen
ziemlich viel also ich glaube viele
haben diese 19 Grad Regel hier bei uns
auch zu Hause geht jetzt in den außen
wäre es nicht macht zahlt dann halt mehr
aber ich glaube es wäre wünschenswert
und wir wissen jetzt einfach von dem
Planungen her wir haben einen LG
Terminal das jetzt am Sonntag geöffnet
in rekordseite öffnet das wünsche ich
mir übrigens auch für die
Windkraftausbau und wir haben jetzt
Einsparung und 2025 Prozent in Industrie
gesehen wenn wir das beibehalten werden
wir nach den Zahlen die wir kennen durch
den Winter kommen und dann müssen
natürlich nächstes Jahr die Gasspeicher
wieder füllen
die insolvenzwellen zeichnen sich bisher
nicht in der Form ab ehrlich gesagt
sehen wir die nicht in dieser Form
momentan es gibt sicherlich einzelne
Betriebe die zu kämpfen haben aber im
Wesentlichen sehen wir momentan sogar
konjunkturell wieder leichte Aufschwung
Tendenzen Konsum Konsumklima ist gut
also wenn es gut läuft kommen wir nicht
mal in der technischen Rezession im
nächsten Jahr
den Kopf hin und her ich kann es auch
keine Glaskugel aber man kann ja schon
man kann zumindest die These vertreten
soll ich jetzt mal machen dass man in
diesem harten Winter sieht dass der
Traum der Energiewende zum Albtraum der
Deindustrialisierung führen kann wir
haben jetzt unvorhergesehene Faktoren
das ist doch völlig klar Ukraine kriegt
etc streitet niemand aber wer sagt uns
dass das nicht auch in 4 5 6 8 Jahren
noch mal kommt sie haben jetzt die die
Windräder angesprochen deren Ausbau
vorangetrieben werden soll wir hatten
die letzten Wochen konnte man den
offiziellen Daten enorm entnehmen viele
viele Stunden tagsüber dunkelflaut da
hat sich fast kein einziges Windrad
gedreht diese drei Atomkraftwerke die
wir jetzt momentan noch haben haben
dürfen haben mehr Energie gemacht als
alle 30.000 Windkraftanlagen also ich
glaube wenn wir uns jetzt wirklich mit
diesen Erfahrungen spornstreichs
weiterhin in dieser Energiewende hinein
begeben 2045 komplett CO2 neutral zu
wirtschaften fürchte ich dass wir das
Risiko haben einer der
Industrialisierung entgegen zu laufen
und sie haben selbst gesagt das Angebot
muss erweitert werden deshalb finde ich
man müsste auch wirklich reden über
Atomkraftwerke vielleicht sogar über
Fracking und dieser eingängige Weg der
schreibt mir wirklich nicht mehr
alternativlos zu sein hin zu 100%
erneuerbaren Energien ich glaube dieser
Winter zeigt es vielleicht zeigt ist der
nächste Winter sogar noch schlimmer mehr
Strom sparen also sagen Sie uns wie es
geht haben sie ein paar Tricks auf Lager
was man machen sollte was auf keinen
Fall das so Stecker beim Fernseher raus
und rein der Teekocher oder irgend etwas
einfachste ist wirklich keine
abschaltbare Leiste anzuschaffen also
bei mir zu Hause Waschmaschine kann ich
an Stecker abschalten damit die nicht
bloßweise rumsteht Strom verbraucht
genauso Fernseher also überall einfach
abschalten abschalten abschalten
zack ausmachen nicht bei mir gibt's
nichts auf Standby oder so also kann man
einfach eine ganze Menge machen die
einfachste Sache ist wirklich auch daran
zu denken ich brauche eigentlich nur in
dem Raum wo ich bin Licht
und wie viel Leute müssen unbedingt
immer ihre ganz ganze Häuser erleuchten
Waschlappen
es gibt ja tolle Sache Schwämme die
würden tun ja
keinen herkömmlichen Waschlappen
was eigentlich nicht da ist ich frage
mich dann viel mehr warum eigentlich für
ganz viele Dinge stromgeräte gekauft
werden die vielleicht gar nicht
gebraucht werden